okay
great now let's dive into the material
today so today's topic is carbohydrates
as well as an introduction to
membrane structure and from the very
first class i believe professor yaffi
talked to you about
the four main classes of biological
molecules so
proteins and amino acids you've spent a
lot of time talking about that
nucleic acids is coming up and the other
two are carbohydrates or sugars
and lipids today we're really going to
focus
most of the lecture on carbohydrates
what they are structure something about
nomenclature
and then at the end we're going to talk
a little bit about lipids and basic
membrane structure now carbohydrates and
lipids are really
critical energy storage molecules for
cells
and when we talk about metabolism the
most interesting part of this course
after spring break we're going to delve
into this
in a lot more detail but
sugars are also very important to
understand nucleic acid structure
turns out membranes are essential for
signal transduction
those are the two major topics that
professor gaffy is going to talk about
for the rest of his time and so this
year we're going to try something
different and have me
introduce at least some of these topics
now which will
deal with some redundancies that
otherwise might have existed
and maybe set it up better for him to uh
to to
discuss some of the lectures coming up
now today's lecture is unfortunately
topically a little bit
disjointed but it still has
important information about biochemistry
and it will help us all speak the same
language both for the upcoming lectures
on from uh from professor yaffi as well
as things that
i will start off with when i come back
and it's a nice way to sort of ease back
in after the exam
okay so what is a carbohydrate or a
sugar
so let's break this down and so it's
carbo
hydrate
okay so a carbohydrate is effectively
carbon in some ratio with
water so all carbohydrates have the same
chemical formula cnh2on
and so there are some deviations from
this in biology sometimes you can
introduce a heteroatom
phosphate sulfur nitrogen etc
technically these are not carbohydrates
although they're often lumped together
with carbohydrates and why would nature
do this because it changes some of the
chemical properties that can be useful
for either structural
or signaling reasons you may encounter
these later um certainly in other
classes
but we're not going to talk much more
about that today we're really just going
to focus on
the base carbohydrate cnh2n
structure now
carbohydrates come in different forms
and so they can come
as single units
with that structure these are so called
monocyte
or these single units can come together
to form various polymers
and those polymers could be two units
so-called disaccharides
so two sugars stuck together
or many units and so sometimes those are
referred to as oligosaccharides
or polysaccharides
and there's really no clear distinction
between you know a few chains together
oligosaccharides many polysaccharides
they're somewhat used
interchangeably now you guys have almost
certainly heard of
many of these things so what's a
monosaccharide so a good example of that
is glucose so glucose is of course the
main sugar that exists
in your blood what's a disaccharide
so common one is sucrose so sucrose
is a disaccharide so two sugars stuck
together
glucose plus fructose you've probably
heard of both of those things before
sucrose is of course table sugar it's
what you would have mixed into your
coffee if you had that this morning
and an example of a polysaccharide is
starch so what's in a potato
all right now clearly these are all
sugars they're all relevant to a human
diet
you would never confuse you've probably
not knowingly tasted glucose it's not
particularly sweet
sucrose is much sweeter and a potato is
not necessarily sweet at all
yet this really points out that
how these sugars are built the different
structures
matter a lot they matter for things like
how you taste them
in your diet and how carbohydrates are
built
also matters a lot for all kinds of
aspects of biology
which is why it's somewhat important to
at least understand
some of what we're talking about a
common language about
how to describe these molecules
okay so the simplest
biological sugars have three carbons
that are least commonly used these are
referred to
as trioses and if we
take the general formula c3 h2o
3 okay and we say what are two ways that
we can
satisfy that formula there's two main
ways we can do it
one is like this
okay so if you add up count all the
carbons hydrogens and oxygens
you will see that that is c3 h2o
o3 this molecule is called
glyceraldehyde
and the other way we can do this is like
this
okay again three carbons three waters if
you add up all the atoms
this molecule is called dihydroxy
acetone
and these are sugars same
chemical formula different chemical
structure
that has a term that's called an isomer
and it turns out that we can chemically
interconvert these molecules in the
following way
and so if we carry out this chemistry
okay
we will get this intermediate
okay and that will allow you to
interconvert
glyceraldehyde this aldehyde
with this ketone dihydroxyacetone
and the enzyme class that carries this
out
is a class of enzymes called isomerases
and this is exactly the chemistry that
that enzyme would use
to interconvert these two forms of
this trials this three carbon sugar
molecule
all right now if we look at
dihydroxyacetone
there's no stereocenter here what do i
mean by a stereocenter
that's a carbon that has reminder from
512 carbon that has
four different subs non-equivalent
substituents
around it however if you look at
glyceraldehyde
that carbon in the middle is a
stereocenter
okay four non-equivalent groups around
it and so there's two ways that i can
draw
glyceraldehyde i can draw it like this
okay or i could draw it
like this
all right so two different ways so the
one on the
left here is d glyceraldehyde
and the one on the right is l
glyceraldehyde
okay and i know that this is review some
people are good at
seeing these things some people are not
i brought a couple models here
here's like just you know the blue and
the brown
are two stereocenters with four
different constituents on them
no way you can twist these around to
make them identical molecules
why does this matter well enzyme active
sites
are going to fit this molecule different
than this molecule
and this is why these stereoisomers
matter
so much for biology
it's also something that's really hard
to accomplish if you think about how do
you actually generate stereoisomers if
you were
in an organic chemistry lab really hard
but biology does this all the time and
the real reason is
is because it's enzymes that ultimately
catalyze these inner conversions and
different stereoisomers will fit
differently into
enzyme active sites now the way that
i've been drawing these sugars
is a convention called a fissure
projection
and when drawn in this way the
convention is
is that so you put the carbonyl towards
the top
if the o h group the alcohol
is pointing to the right that's d
if it's pointing to the left that's l
and so d pointing to the right l
pointing to the left like amino acids
biology has chosen one stereo
chemistry for most biological sugars
because of course enzymes act on them
and so in biology
it's d sugars
this is in contrast to l amino acids
and so if you can remember that sugars
are d you know that amino acids are the
opposite or if you remember that amino
acids are l
you can remember that sugars are the
opposite okay
all right so dihydroxyacetone
is really the only sugar with
three or more carbons that doesn't have
a chiral center
everything else will and so if i go to
a four carbon sugar
draw a couple of them here so
okay so here's c4h2o4
drawn with a ketone if you look at this
this is a chiral center oh group is
pointing to the right
this is a d sugar if i had drawn it with
the o h group on this side
it would be an l sugar all right if i
draw this
sugar as a different isomer this time
with an
aldehyde
okay now we encounter
a bit of an issue because now i have one
two
stereocenters okay so if there's
two stereocenters that means there's
two to the n ways
that i can draw this as a stereoisomer
and so you can see that this could get
really complicated
very quickly now
this sugar obviously is a d because i
drew both o h groups
two pointing to the right but
you can imagine i could draw one this
way or one that way
and so how do you know if it's a d or an
l sugar and so
the convention is is that whether or not
a sugar is designated as d
or l refers to the stereocenter
that is furthest away from the carbonyl
and so this is the relevant stereocenter
that says it's a d sugar so what do i
mean i can draw
and then any other sugar would have a
different name
and so what do i mean by that let me
draw this a few different ways
and so the sugar that i've drawn here is
referred to
as d erythrose
all right if i draw it
now i have the oh group on the carbon
furthest from the carbonyl pointing to
the left
so this would be l
erythros
and if i draw it differently by altering
the stereochemistry of
this carbon now it has a different name
and so this
carbon is d or this sugar is d
threose all right makes sense if i
flip the oh group to this side it would
be l
throws all right so lots of
possibilities
turns out nature only uses a subset
of these stereoisomers and makes them
relevant for biology
for example d erythros is something that
you will encounter when we talk about
metabolism later in the course
d3os as far as i know is not used in
biology i would never say it's never
used in biology never bet against
biology it can do absolutely
everything there's always an exception
somewhere but in general d3os is not
something that
really exists at least commonly
in nature all right so
if we go through and you look at all of
these different
sugars that i've drawn you can see
that they either have an aldehyde or
they have a ketone
somewhere in the molecule all right so
if you have an aldehyde
these sugars are generically referred to
as
aldoses all right and if you have a
ketone
an internal carbonyl these are
generically referred to
as ketosis
now you might say as you start getting
to
longer and longer sugars you could put
the ketone
anywhere along the sugar and there would
be a ton of different
possibilities but it turns out ketosis
always have the carbonyl as the second
carbon in from the end the reason for
that is
is because biology as you will see when
we talk about metabolism
interconverts these via isomerase
reactions
and so you can't use an isomerase
reaction to interconvert a ketose and an
aldose
unless the ketone is one carbon away
from
the end of the sugar and so this fact
really limits some of the diversity of
ketosis that can actually
exist in nature now
most important biological sugars at
least the most common ones
end up having six carbons or five
carbons
and these are referred to as hexoses
or aldos or pentoses sorry
so much nomenclature okay so six carbon
sugars are hexoses
five carbon sugars are pentoses and
if we just talk about the hexoses you're
very familiar with a couple of them okay
and so
one that we mentioned earlier blood
sugar glucose looks like this
okay so this molecule is
d glucose
it's a d sugar because the stereocenter
here furthest from
the carbonyl points o h group
points to the right so it's a d sugar
it's an aldose because it has an
aldehyde
all right and it's a hexose because it
has one two
three four five six carbons and what
makes it glucose
is the stereochemistry of these other
sites that end up being this is
the molecule glucose now if i carry out
that
isomerase reaction that i
showed you earlier
okay so it'll give me this intermediate
i'm going to draw the whole thing
then i interconvert that aldose now it
becomes
a ketose
okay this is d fructose
another common sugar that certainly is
in the news a lot
d sugar because the stereocenter
furthest from the carbonyl
points to the right makes it a d sugar
it's a ketose
it's a hexose this organization of other
stereocenters is what makes it d
fructose all right now if we go through
and we
count these there's four stereocenters
in glucose
three stereocenters in fructose that
means
two to the end there are 16 ways i can
make
a ketose aldose eight ways i can make a
ketose i'm sorry an aldos hexose eight
ways i can make a
ketose hexose among those that's even 12
different ways that i can have d hexoses
that are a ketocernal dose could be very
very complicated
but it turns out fructose is the only
d hexose ketose that really is relevant
for nature
there's only two other molecules related
to glucose only two other
hexose aldoses that are sugars used in
nature
you've probably heard of these as well
i'll draw them
to illustrate a different point
okay so this molecule is
galactose
important sugar found in milk
all right if i draw glucose next to it
again
glucose
so
these two sugars differ here
okay the stereochemistry there okay
so there are i guess isomers
of each other there's a special name for
it we'll get to a second so that's how
galactose is related to glucose the
other
major aldos hexose is this one
okay this is d-mannose
okay this differs from glucose
here that carbon
at that carbon by the way by convention
the way that
you number carbons in sugars is you
start with the end
that's closest to the carbonyl either
the aldehyde or
the carbon one up from the ketone so
this would be
carbon one two three four
five six so galactose differs from
glucose at carbon four
glucose differs from mannose at carbon
two
these have names these isomers have
names
in relation to each other and so two
sugars
that differ by one part of
stereochemistry so galactose to glucose
or glucose to mannose are called epimers
and these can be interconverted by
enzymes called
epimerases we'll talk about how these
work
later in the course and so glucose is an
epimer
of galactose glucose is an epimer of
manos
manos is not an epimer of galactose
because mannose and galactose differ at
both
carbon two and carbon four their
stereochemistry
okay why is that relevant because if
you're going to interconvert
galactose and mannose you would have to
do it in two steps
two different epimerase reactions to
interconvert
those two sugars all right
great so we've discussed
now all of the major
hexoses that nature uses we've discussed
all the major
trioses that nature uses
the other major length of sugars that
ends up being important in biochemistry
is the five carbon sugars the pentoses
and so i want to mention a couple
pentoses and do so in a way that will
allow me to
basically solidify some of the
nomenclature that i've
gone through and of course one of the
five carbon sugars ribose
is really critical to nucleic acid
structure which is one of the reasons
why
we're talking about this at this point
in the course
okay so this is a pentose one two three
four
five carbon sugar okay d
ribose all right it's a d sugar because
the stereocenter furthest from the
carbonyl
points to the right it's an aldose
because it has an aldehyde group i can
act on this with an isomerase
not going to draw out the isomerase
reaction again it's exactly what i drew
before
if i did this now i turn this into
a ketose
okay pentose because it's five carbons
ketos because it has a ketone d sugar
because the stereocenter furthers from
the carbonyl points to the right
this has the name of d ribulose
all right and it turns out that there's
an important epimer
of d ribulose that's found in nature the
epimer changes the stereochemistry
at carbon three carbon one two three
four five that's carbon three and so
if this was acted on by an epimerase
that did that you get this sugar
also a pentose also a ketose
a d sugar
but an epimer of ribulose it's called d
xyulose okay it's an epimer because
of xylose and ribulose are epimers
because they differ by stereochemistry
only at
one position i'll just say right off the
bat
you should not memorize names of sugars
in their structures these are things you
can
look up in books the point of going
through all this is just to
expose you to some of the nomenclature
remind you
about stereochemistry i realize these
are
basic things many of you have already
encountered this
some of you find this very easy some
people find these sort of spatial things
more
difficult this is very well reviewed
though
in textbooks or other places online if
you need to
to to a look it up but the key thing is
just to remember this nomenclature
because it'll make it easier for us to
talk about
sugars um later in the course all right
let's take a
short break so i can get some board
space back
and then we'll build off of some of
these concepts in a minute
i've been drawing all of these sugars as
straight chains but you probably know
from
high school or from looking at dna or
rna
that the ribose there is not a straight
chain but instead
forms a ring and in fact in solution
particular aqueous solution
sugars particularly five carbons and
longer almost always exist as rings
and there is a very clear reason for
this and you probably remember
from 512 organic chemistry that
alcohols will react with aldehydes and
ketones in solution
okay and so here i have a model of
glucose and fructose if you want to come
and play with them
and so if you look at this and you just
look at the model
you see that this oxygen right here this
alcohol
in space is very close or can be moved
to be very close
to this aldehyde here on the end of the
molecule
or the same thing here with fructose
right here's a you know
here's a alcohol very close in space
with this
ketone all right so what happens
in this situation well if you have this
is review of organic chemistry
okay so here's any generic aldehyde
here's some alcohol
okay so if those things
react you end up with this
so-called hemi
acetol or the same thing
if i do it with a
ketone
and an alcohol
now you get
this hemi
ketal okay now given that you have an
alcohol
reacting with a carbonyl an aldehyde or
a ketone
on the same molecule well what happens
is you effectively get
a ring with oxygen being one of the
components of the ring and so
if we draw this for glucose
okay so this is d glucose
all right and so if the
alcohol here on carbon one two three
four
five interacts with the
aldehyde on carbon one okay
you can play with the model and see that
that is
the one that's close in space you now
end up getting
this
okay this where you get a ring between
carbons one
and five okay we can number the rest of
them two three
four five six all right
or if i turn this molecule so that you
can now
draw it in a slightly more chemically
proper way
okay now you basically have
this is carbon one two
three four five
six okay so carbon five
oxygen from carbon five now bound to
carbon
one gives you this six membered
ring structure the six-membered ring
structure is reminiscent
of an organic molecule called a
looks like that called pyran
and so the six-membered ring in a sugar
is also referred to as a
pyranose all right
so that's the first thing the second
thing
is that this whole business
can be very tedious to draw in fact it's
very tedious drawing sugars in general
as i'm sure you are
would agree with me if you're taking
notes during this lecture
and so oftentimes
these pyranoses like glucose are drawn
with
shorthand and the shorthand is as
follows
okay where i basically represent
the oh groups as simply lines
and so this is another shorthand to draw
that pyranose form of glucose again
carbon one
two three four five
six okay now the last thing is you can
see i didn't draw the o h group there on
carbon one
and that's because by making this
pyranose ring
if you look at carbon one i have now
generated a new
stereocenter okay and so carbon one
now has four non-equivalent groups on it
which means i could draw the oh group at
carbon one
in two different ways and so this is
carbon one
i could draw it such that the oh group
points down
or i could draw it such that
the oh group points up
and those are two different molecules
and so there's a naming convention for
this
too and so if the oh group points down
using this way of drawing the molecule
it's called alpha if the o h group
points up
it's called beta all right
and so this alpha versus beta
ends up being structurally different
because it puts
the basically that
that oh group pointing in a very
different position
in space okay so if i make a ring here
with glucose
all right and the oh group is pointing
here versus there
very different position in space and
this has implications for how you build
bonds for disaccharides and
polysaccharides
that make structural differences and
we'll cover this a lot when we get to
metabolism but it should be very clear
now that glucose if you just take a
solution of glucose and put it in water
it is not one thing there's actually
multiple different forms it can have it
could be
as i drew it up here with the oh group
pointing down
this would be alpha d
gluco because it's glucose
pyranose
because it's in the pyrinos
ring form i could have drawn it with the
oh group
pointing up different molecule that
would be beta
d gluco
pyrinos or
it could just be the open chain d
glucose i was drawing
earlier all right all of those are
perfectly
legitimate ways for glucose to exist
in solution all right now it turns out
that
in reality about a third of it in
solution is this two-thirds is that
and a trace amount is this okay
and that's uh you know
has to do with just what is more
favorable forms or not
okay but which form it's in actually
matters
um for structural reasons as we'll see
later in the course
now the final complexity is is that
this ring is not flat okay so if i
actually take
glucose here and make a form of it
okay so here's my glucose molecule
there's no way for me to make this
completely flat
say like benzene and so there's really
two different
pyranose conformations that can be
formed
i'll try to draw them but they're harder
to draw here's a
overhead that you can look at it's
easier
but basically you can have it
form this so-called boat
form okay or
this so-called chair form so there's the
boat
versus the chair conformation
glucose turns out prefers the chair
conformation and there's sort of an
interesting thing that comes from this
because if you take
beta d glucopyranose all right
it turns out of all the hexoses
that exist in possible hexoses that
exist
the form of of a hexose aldose that best
spreads out all the hydroxyl groups is
beta-d glucopyranose right the more
common one in solution
why is this matter well because if this
has this reactive aldehyde bound up
in this stable ring structure it's less
likely to react with other aldehydes in
the cell
and so this is likely why nature chose
d-glucose as the most common
storage sugar why it's sugar in your
blood
because it's the most stable hexose
that's out there
all right and it's not just a random
reason that nature picked this one but
actually because
of real chemical stability issues for
why it's
there all right now
i want to mention that ketosis also can
form rings
and i'm going to use this as an example
to show you
that a keto so here's fructose
okay so this is d fructose and so
turns out this can form two possible
rings it can form a five-membered ring
or a six-membered ring
so how do i form a five-membered ring
some colors
okay so if i take the carbon here from
carbon one two three four
five the hydroxyl from carbon five
form a ring there all right now i get
this molecule
okay let's number these one two three
four five six okay or if i
now turn this so that i draw it in the
way you're probably more used
to seeing it
i'm going to use the shorthand here so
this here would be carbon
1 2 3
4 five six
hydroxyl from carbon five forming a bond
to carbon two that creates a new
stereocenter
at carbon two oh group is pointing up
so this is a beta
sugar okay aoh group pointing up so this
here as i drew it would be
beta d
fructo and this is a
furanose why is that because the organic
molecule
that's a five-membered ring with an
oxygen in it is a furan
and so the five-membered ring is
referred to as a furanose
beta d fructofyranos if i drawn it with
the oh group putting down it would be
alpha d
fructophironos okay there's another
possible ring
i can do instead i take the hydroxyl
from carbon 6
and do that form a ring
now i'm going to form a six membered
ring
okay we have carbon
one two three four five
six so if i now turn this
okay so this here now i drew the o h
group pointing down so it's
an alpha if i drew it up it would be
beta
so this is alpha d
fructo
pyranose six membered ring
version of fructose five-membered ring
version of fructose so lots of
non-equivalent ways i can draw
fructose and it turns out
these actually matter and they matter
for real things that
probably matter to you and so i brought
with me here two different
sweeteners okay this is corn syrup
this is honey has anyone ever i'm sure
most of you have had honey has anyone
ever tasted corn syrup
come on someone's tasted corn syrup is
it sweet
which one's sweeter honey by far
much much much sweeter i used to have it
so you guys could come up and taste them
but i couldn't come up with a way to do
that in a sanitary way so i gave up on
it but
nonetheless much sweeter than that it
turns out these are not pure fructose
they're a combination of sugars but
their composition is actually
from a chemical standpoint similar
amounts of
fructose in each one and it turns out
that honey
is beta d fructopyranose
whereas corn syrup is beta
defructophyranos
all right so same sugar
different structure one's a fair nose
one's a pyranose
tastes very differently to you one being
much more sweet
one being much less sweet okay
now of course i also want to talk about
ribose
because it's the thing that you guys are
going to talk about
the most next because it's in nucleic
acids and so just as a reminder
here's ribose it's a aldose and a
pentose
okay so this is d-ribose
ribose as you know from high school
forms five-membered rings
that's because it links alcohol on
carbon
four to the aldehyde on carbon one
and that gives you
this ring structure
okay okay now number carbons one
two three four alcohol and carbon four
forming a ring to the aldehyde on carbon
one
this is carbon five all right and
the way i drew it oh group pointing up
so this is
beta d
ribo firanos will be the proper way to
have it
and so when you guys talk about this in
dna
well the base is going to be linked to
carbon 1. it's going to replace that ox
the
hydroxyl group the beta form of the
hydroxyl group with the nitrogen
and you're going to talk about bonds
being from the 5 prime or the 3 prime
end those are those hydroxyl groups
that's where five prime and three prime
comes from because those are the five in
the three position
on ribose great
perfect all right so we will
return to carbohydrates
in great detail we'll discuss how we
combine
different carbohydrates different
monosaccharides to make disaccharides
and polysaccharides
how these different structural
properties end up
mattering for things like energy storage
as well as to produce various structural
molecules
that can be important for different
cells and organisms but for the
remaining
you know part of the class today i
really want to shift topics to now
discuss
a completely different class of
biomolecules
and that's lipids so as i said earlier
the reason we're going to do this is
because
coming up for professor yaffi's lectures
lipids end up being really important
molecules for various aspects of cell
signaling
they're also very important for energy
transduction which is why
i'm talking about them as well
we will spend a lot of time later
talking about lipids in great detail
but really what i want to focus on today
is how lipids are used to create
membranes that is barriers that really
separate
the outside world from the inside of
cells
things that make compartments within
cells
and these things also end up being
surfaces
where you can have key things happen so
you reduce spatial complexity if you go
to a 2d surface
versus a 3d surface which is part of why
they're so important in
signal transduction but to talk about
these i have to
introduce first of all what is
a lipid okay so
lipids are a class of molecules you
think of them as fats
that's sort of how they fit in the
nutritional standpoint of what we'll
talk about but first i want to give a
general definition of what
a lipid is now there's lots of different
classes of lipids and
we'll cover these later in the course
but in general at the highest level
almost all lipids consist of two pieces
consists of something called a fatty
acid
that's esterified to an alcohol
okay so what is a fatty acid
well a fatty acid
is really any molecule that has a
carboxylic acid group okay so
there's a carboxylic acid and then
hooked up to that carboxylic acid
is a whole bunch of
saturated hydrocarbons alkyl chains
okay oftentimes fatty acid would be
drawn
like this right because of all the
different
saturated chains okay so acid group on
one end
really greasy alkyl chain on the other
and it turns out that this can be
esterified to an alcohol so here's just
a generic
alcohol and as you
certainly remember from
organic chemistry if i form i can use an
alcohol and an acid to form
an ester okay and so then that would be
okay so now i have basically this ester
bond and this esterification between
some lipid species and a fatty acid
in general is the general thing that
leads to
class of molecules known as lipids
now why this is particularly useful
for biology is that this long greasy
alkyl chain is not water soluble
all right so if you take oil from your
cabinet
canola oil or olive oil or whatever and
you pour
it in water what happens
it doesn't mix together you get these
globs of oil floating
in the water okay and so
if you want to form a barrier between
two aqueous compartments
a way to do this is to have basically a
hydrophobic layer
a membrane basically separate the two
aqueous compartments okay the inside and
the outside of the cell
now if i take a lipid
and the lipid i form this ester and it
doesn't have
a charged group anywhere on the molecule
this is sometimes referred to is a
neutral lipid so what do i mean by
neutral lipid it's basically
taking this which is intrinsically a
fatty acid is intrinsically a
polar molecule it has this carboxylic
acid
on the end of it okay but if i form an
ester linkage to an alcohol and the
alcohol has no charge on it
now it's just this really greasy
molecule and it turns out that's exactly
what is in your olive oil
or in your canola oil in your cabinet
it's basically
a bunch of fatty acids long ankle chains
esterified to non-charged alcohols which
makes this
neutral lipid this greasy molecule which
is great for energy storage in plants
something we'll talk about
but if you want to mix it together with
water it doesn't do very well okay so if
you go to make salad dressing and you
pour your oil in with your vinegar the
aqueous thing
you get a bunch of droplets you don't
get a solution
and if you think about it that's not
very good at generating an interface
between two compartments right you just
get a bunch of droplets you actually
don't get
an interface between two compartments
so if you want to make an interface you
have to do something different
you need to have a charge group like on
this fatty acid
that's going to be happy sticking
towards the aqueous side
and then a hydrophobic portion that's
going to be happy
sticking to form a barrier okay
effectively
that's what soap is all right so if you
want to wash your hands and use canola
oil it doesn't work very well right
okay but what happens if you have a
bunch of greasy stuff in the water and
you take a drop of
dawn dish detergent and drop it in the
water you get this
immediate barrier that forms across the
top
as you get this film where you basically
align up all these charged hydrophilic
parts to the aqueous pieces
and all of the greasy parts to the
to the hydrophobic side okay so you end
up having this
you know nice charged molecule
with this long hydrophobic part so you
have a hydrophilic end
and a hydrophobic end
and that ends up being very useful as a
way to form an aqueous
um um uh hydrophobic interface
and this is exactly how soap works as
i'm sure you've learned in other classes
as an aside you know how you make soap
you basically boil
the neutral lipids in lye okay so
boiling it in base
if you remember from organic chemistry
will break the ester linkage
and now you have these molecules and
that's how you make soap
all right now the way biology does this
is they actually assemble lipids
that effectively have that same property
okay
where basically they have a head group
from the alcohol that's charged with the
hydrophobic group
contributed from these fatty acids and
this is what allows things to
assemble into membranes
and so membranes are largely made up of
and certainly for the purposes of the
upcoming lectures
so-called phospholipids
so what is a phospholipid well on a
phospholipid
the alcohol part of the lipid is derived
from a molecule
called glycerol all right
so glycerol looks like this
okay so this is glycerol all right
three carbon molecule three alcohols
actually very similar if you look back
in your notes to dihydroxyacetone the
difference between glycerol and
dihydroxyacetone
is carbon two is an alcohol here before
it was a ketone
turns out that's where glycerol comes
from dihydroxyacetone
getting turned into to glycerol and
basically what a phospholipid is is that
you esterify
a fatty acid to two of the alcohols
and another phosphate and charged
alcohol
to the other hydroxyl group
so what do i mean by that so like this
so here's
ester linkage number one i'll draw it
this way
just for ease this is to carbon two
here's ester linkage number two
okay so that's a fatty acid a sterified
two
two and three and then
you now make an ester to a phosphate
okay so there's a phosphate at carbon
one
and then you make another ester linkage
to another alcohol where
r equals alcohol
and that alcohol also turns out to be
charged
and so the most
common phospholipid
membrane lipid is a molecule called phos
the tidal
choline which is that structure
with the r group being this
alcohol
okay so this is choline
okay and so phosphatidylcholine
is basically that structure
okay so this is phosphatidylcholine
drawn out in all of this glory so you
have this
hydro philic end
here you have a hydrophobic end
okay that's good this can point towards
the aqueous side this can point towards
the greasy side and make a nice
interface and so another
common word for phosphatidylcholine an
old word for it
is a molecule called lecipine
anyone read the labels on the side of
your food ever
in fact i think there's an old
commercial that makes fun of this soy
lecithin what's that i don't want that
in my ice cream
okay well what is lecithin it's
phosphatidylcholine
it's basically why is this done well
it's commonly added to ice cream
because what is ice cream and it's an
emulsion between fat
the cream and sugar which is
pretty aqueous soluble as you might
guess from looking at what we drew
earlier today
and so by putting phosphatidylcholine in
your ice cream
you basically stabilize this emulsion
between the aqueous and the fat face so
this is why it's added to lots
of food and in fact it says soy lecithin
an emulsifier
that's why it's added you can do this
yourself this is a common trick that
many
cooks know so if you make salad dressing
you put a little mayonnaise in your
salad dressing okay
why do you do that well mayonnaise has
eggs in it eggs have a lot of
phosphatidylcholine
that mayonnaise that you add into your
salad dressing
basically stabilizes that emulsion
between the oil and the vinegar
and helps it be more stable and
distribute better across
your your lettuce i think my favorite
example of this is who's made chocolate
chip cookies
everyone's done this right okay so how
do you make chocolate chip cookies so
you take
butter and sugar all right fat and
something is very non very polar aqueous
soluble sugar
and you try to mix them together you
have to cream it right and
that takes forever it's a pain in the
butt it doesn't come together very well
and so you get lazy and you put the egg
in there and then it all comes together
really really easily
right so why is that the egg is the
emulsifier that actually brings it
together
whereas trying to get the butter and
sugar to make your sure your cookies
nice and fluffy
is a lot harder because you're really
trying to get these two things to come
together and it's
basically this exact chemistry that's
taking place
when you're doing that active cooking
all right now phosphatidylcholine
is not the only phospholipid
found in membranes but i'll just
quickly mention what a couple of the
other ones
are
so it turns out you have two other
major phospholipids by abundance and
then another phospholipid
that's really important for signaling so
i'll list them here first
so there's phosphatidyl
serine
phosphatidyl
ethanolamine
these it turns out phosphatidylcholine
phospital serine phosphatidyl
ethanolamine is what makes up the
majority
of the phospholipids in cell membranes
and then there's a much more minor
phospholipid that's important for
signaling which is
phosphatidyl inositol
so what are these so serine ethanoline
and inositol are just
like choline different alcohols that can
be esterified to the phosphate
in exactly the same way i did for
phosphatidylcholine
and so what's phosphatidylserine
so if you remember this is
okay so this here is the amino acid
serine okay i'm sure you remember that
if we
esterify that alcohol
to the phosphate
okay there's phosphatidyl serine
okay
what's ethanolamine look like so
ethanolamine is
this alcohol
okay so that's ethanolamine
okay sterify the alcohol
the phosphate esterify that phosphate
to glycerol
okay phosphatidyl ethanol amine
and the last one is inositol so what is
inositol well inositol is a
six-membered
hydrocarbon ring
where all of the carbons
have an alcohol on them and so if i
esterify one of these alcohols
on inositol of course there's a
if i sterify one of those alcohols
to the phosphate to make phosphatidyl
and acetol
turns out that that ends up being a
really useful
lipid to make for signaling and you'll
hear a lot from this
about this in a couple of contexts i
believe from professor yaffi
later in the course all right so
this having these
general membrane structure this general
phospholipid structure where you have
this hydrophobic part of the molecule
and the hydrophilic
part of the molecule is really what
allows
these lipids to come together to form
these
membrane bilayers that are often drawn
like this okay and so when i'm drawing
it
like this basically what those two wavy
lines represent those are the
hydrophobic fatty acid parts
and this is the hydrophilic
so-called head group
okay that's the charged alcohol stuck on
to the end of the and to to
to to the phosphate on on the glycerol
all right and these of course assemble
such that all of the
hydrophilic head groups face
an aqueous compartment on either side
okay and then you have this nice
hydrophobic
portion that is a membrane and that is
what
can create a barrier between two
different compartments
in cells okay now just to put this into
context
for the protein structure stuff that you
learned about okay
so when you learn about all the
different ways that you have protein
structure of course you have amino acids
that are hydrophilic amino acids that
are hydrophobic
if you have a protein that's floating in
solution it has all the hydrophilic
parts on the outside and the hydrophobic
parts in the middle
all right but you can imagine that you
can also have proteins
that assemble to sit such that they span
the membrane so hydrophobic parts that
interact with the hydrophobic part the
inner part of the membrane
hydrophilic parts on either side these
can form channels these can form all
kinds of ways to move stuff
across membranes or
you might think that you might have a
protein that does something like that
hydrophobic part on one end hydrophilic
part on the other and really floats
on the surface of a membrane and you
will see
that the way cell signaling works is
is that you basically have lots of
protein complexes that will assemble
that membranes two-dimensional space
those membranes as well as some of the
membrane lipids can then act as
messengers
that allow cells to carry out various
signals and i will leave that
to professor yaffi to talk about
all right so i will also come back
and discuss membranes in a very
different context
in the context of metabolism during the
second half of the course
because it turns out a lot of energy
transduction and the way cells really
store energy
also ends up being really important with
respect to membranes
all right you guys are lucky you get out
a little bit early today
this is the first time that we've done
the lectures this way so i don't have my
timing quite right
but i will see you guys again for
uh metabolism after spring break
you